um and even if you look at it's
interesting in history you can look at a
lot of like peasants wives seem to kind
of there were systems to keep them from
acting out right but a lot of these
King's wives were in history
sorry ladies you know
um because they're around all the other
high-value guys and it's the same thing
and I think the problem is we keep
telling everybody that we're so special
and unique and as people we're really
not that special we're unique we're just
people you know we have a nature and the
problem is we equip women
um to act on the worst part of our
nature which is that we're emotional
we're feelings first we're never happy
and a lot of times we get greedy